[Music]
happiness is [ __ ]
you think Picasso was happy think
Hemingway was hello art worth the damn
was ever created out of happiness I
could tell you that much
that's where we're all such a miserable
[ __ ] so you know you're a miserable
[ __ ] do you think I'm an idiot of
course I know there's only one place
left in the world that processes
Kodachrome and that's Duane's photo in
persons Kansas your father found four
roles he shot a really long time ago and
he wants you to drive them I've not
spoken to the man in over a decade he's
dying
let's go burning daylight what you're
going to huh unless you want to give me
my shot he's one of the world's greatest
living photographers remember every shot
of everything you remember all yeah
when's my birthday for every 19th
February 19th man should know his father
no matter what kind of bastard he is
merge onto i-80 West that thing for a
second the hell are you doing we're
taking the scenic route
this was your room yeah you can tell a
lot about someone's past from the music
they listen to what can I say I was a
moody kid that's not how I see it
I don't kid myself that I was any kind
of husband or father you have a great
big life
[Applause]
maybe it comes from them in the past
given a bus or watch stuff in my life
I'm tired oh geez it pictures to stop
time
[Music]
moments to eternity why'd you come on
this trip let's see how you measure up
against the colossal bastard I've hated
all these years how am i doing you're on
your own
I remember better day
[Music]
[Music]